i don't know who we had on was it
michael say i don't know who we had on
it was somebody that we had on we were
talking i said listen
my opinion is the crypto community is
becoming a political party and somebody
better win them early before somebody
else does i think that that party is for
you to take about 100 so i don't know if
you guys are going after that party and
this party is not going to get this
small it's going to get bigger and
bigger and they're right here in miami
we already have plans in new york state
to allow new york city to accept
cryptocurrency for all taxes fines and
fees that's part of my policy right that
we can make cryptocurrency the norm
right so we already can do that 100 so i
i want to i'm sorry go ahead and
bitcoiners didn't really care for eric
adams because he was like oh yes we're
going to be very pro bitcoin and then he
you know did things with
against other people's um uh rights like
making them do the um you know vaccine
mandates and all that stuff for masking
in schools like just
very contrary positions to being a pro
bitcoin person so we saw right through
that we even want nuclear power in new
york state so that we can actually
create a very easy blockchain mining
right we can make green blockchain
mining we can allow that we can support
that in new york state new york state is
the worst by the way for cryptocurrency
because we have a bit license which was
the absolute scam magnum lowsky decided
he used to run our financial um agency
so then he created this insane maze to
get a bit license then left and now he's
a consultant so you have to pay him
hundred thousand dollars to get the
license that he created yeah well that
by the way is legal it's just unethical
yeah totally legal yeah
i would also say just to the idea of
cryptocurrency and specifically bitcoin
that libertarians have to recognize how
important this issue is because this to
me is like the most important thing um
in in the same sense that hundreds of
years ago you know the separation of
church and state was the most important
thing that really ended religious wars
you really don't have religious wars
anymore unless there's governments who
are you know in bed with religions who
are trying to impose themselves on other
governments and what we need today in
the united states of america more than
anything is the separation of money in
the state the separation of banking and
the state this is the cause of so many
of our problems right now is that the
currency is controlled by the government
this allows us to spend way beyond our
means to to pull things off that we
could never pull off if the government
wasn't just printing money out of thin
air the entire idea that we're going to
go around and you know occupy foreign
countries for 20 years in the middle
east with nothing to show for it try
doing that if you had to actually tax
the people the money try gaining popular
support for that if every month people
had to pay for the war in afghanistan
that thing would have been over by
christmas of 2001 yeah and so and so
many of these things and the same thing
with the lockdowns i mean try
maintaining the lockdowns if you
couldn't just print up trillions of
dollars in 2020 there's no way it could
have been done so this is really like
the federal reserve and the money
printing is the lifeblood of the
leviathan that's what we need to attack
and that's why bitcoin is such an
incredible you know like has so much
potential was that those people should
be libertarian was that the whole
impetus of creating bitcoin yeah 2000 i
believe i believe so when satoshi
nakamoto was like i don't like this uh
bailout drama that's going on in new
york city and wall street and occupy
wall street and that's how we started it
was essentially a cause and effect of
exactly what you're talking about dave
yeah bitcoin cryptocurrency blockchain
that's all libertarianism applied to a
problem that is a libertarian solution
to a statist problem so coming out of
the bailouts and tarp and too big to
fail and all of that the realization
that the the the central banking system
that we have is basically a game of
monopoly where all of you have to play
by the rules of monopoly but when it's
my turn i go over to the banker and say
give me a trillion monopoly notes and
stick them all with the debt for it what
would happen in that game is exactly how
our how everything is playing out right
now you have a small handful of people
who get richer and richer and richer
because they have the access to the the
funds the money that's being printed out
more than anyone else the cost of
everything's going through the roof
because they can spend want and lead
because it's not their money there's mal
investment that's leading to uh you know
these bubbles in the economy the the
real estate bubble the stock market
bubble uh the student debt bubble all of
that is because money's just being
thrown around when you get government
out of that when you have the market
deciding what money is then not only do
you not have the rampant inflation that
you have right now but you also don't
have the rampant government spending
that you have right now you don't have
the endless wars like like dave said you
don't have the the cronies like you know
like larry said that get to you know
build a system for them to become a be a
millionaire for the rest of their life
all of that goes away because now
government has to do what literally
everyone else has to do prove that they
have value in exchange for the money
they get that's what you do with your
business that's what i did with my
businesses you have to prove that you
have value in exchange for money if you
and i could just walk around with a gun
legally and say hey give me all your
money yeah we'd be very wealthy we also
wouldn't provide much value that's the
problem we have and bitcoin was a
perfect example of instead of trying to
find a political solution to it finding
a market-based solution to a problem
that is still affecting and and just on
top i think sometimes people have this
like kind of attitude that like okay
you're talking about monetary policy
you're talking about economic policy
this is almost in this realm over here
of economics and then there's this realm
of like social issues but this is this
is like it's the most evil thing in the
world man i mean if you look at think
about i mean the way inflation is just
destroying people and who's it destroyed
it's not it's not destroyed
yeah and i think if you actually measure
the cpi the same way they measured it in
the 70s it's even higher than that at
this point the cpi is all kind of bs
anyway i mean it's like they don't
really account for housing and energy
increases and how you know if you're
talking about measuring how this really
impacts people and who does it impact
well not wall street speculators not
billionaires who own hard assets it's
impacting people on fixed incomes it's
impacting you know the retired and the
poor and the working class and this
government spending i mean you go look
at like um
uh i think it's i might have this double
check me on this but i think 10 of the
top of the 13 richest counties are all
the suburbs of washington dc yeah i mean
these are the people who are getting
rich up it's not like this is the
bastion of capitalism there aren't big
factories in washington dc producing
everything they're just the politically
connected they're people in bed with a
weapons company that funds a think tank
that comes up with a piece that we
actually need to go send a whole bunch
of weapons to ukraine
lobbyists
doing their thing and this is like in
the the real application of all this is
like that families get broken up that
men put revolvers in their mouth and
commit suicide that kids are like like
lives are destroyed this is this can't
be removed from a social issue this is
actually and then you look around and
you're like why is the social fabric of
this country like falling apart why is
everyone turned on each other why do we
have such low like cultural standards in
all of this this is all related this all
like kind of came as a result of the
government destroying the economy well
financial sanctions too um are financial
controls on people um this censorship
wouldn't have even been anything anybody
could have thought about three years ago
but now i mean i don't know why
conservatives don't see that they can
just turn your bank account off i mean
look what happened in canada with the
truckers or um even as something is as
big and broad as like with um the
russians and having the swift payment
denied to them you know why would we
give financial sanctions to citizens for
what the movements of their government
do yeah they always convince you it's
going after this bad guy so it's kind of
like hey we're seizing all these assets
of these russian oligarchs and you're
like well was anyone like convicted of
anything in a court of law there's no
but we said russian oligarch so we're
just going to take all his stuff or the
truckers are like the bad people up
there these these working-class people
who are like and you're a putinist if
you think that's right and then all that
and then you go like okay so they they
uh invoked these never uh before used
emergency powers act in canada and
they're seizing people's bank accounts
no due process no one ever proved that
they were at uh uh one of these protests
or donated to one of these protests and
even if they are i don't think they
should have their bank accounts seized
but yeah these type of powers are very
creepy and you know i think americans
are more and more waking up to the idea
of it's easy to be like yeah but the
government would never use them in that
way
but also we never thought the government
was going to lock us in our homes for
months on end
you know covet and these lockdowns have
helped your political party yeah have a
bigger voice it should have
a bigger part of that is yes we have to
show that we have the best ideas yes we
have to show that we actually have a
solution to this endless good cop bad
cop routine between republicans and
democrats where we just things just keep
getting worse and worse whether it's
lockdown tarp the thing that sparked
bitcoin the outrage was an 800 what was
a 798 billion dollar bail that's pocket
change to what they spend now they
routinely spend bills that start with a
t or end with a t you know it's a it's a
trillion dollar bill
three billion two three trillion dollar
billion yeah exactly 800 billion dollars
is like a rounding error now and and
that's only in the span of like less
than 20 years it just keeps getting
worse and worse so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]